should we have Joe come energy it was
just leave him out there Sam Sam with
him let's get Joe back he at least his
sister just checked in oh yeah okay well
tell some jokes now is that what the
plan is
yeah have them put this put them on the
spot they come in guys go what kind of
jokes you got no I'm saying for them
yeah that's what I mean let's have them
come on so you guys floors yours yeah
okay let's see that where they come in
when they come in are they gonna come in
together I hope so
make sure they come in together don't
allow them in here yeah when they come
in let's just go guys floors yours yeah
but he got you do a lot of radio from
enough is that the best when you walk
into a show and they go hey what do you
got you know I did recently which was
really I did Bob and Tom I have never
didn't in their studio it was really fun
to do live odd I'd say we did Mancow
what it was a very bizarre I was I was
in Chicago cha-chang and I was in
Chicago I was doing a chi did a couple
of morning shows and I'd been booked on
Mancow and then I they had me for a
90-minute block but it was the last bit
of press I had two things and the man
came off my age another day before they
canceled so I said to my publicist I bet
they cancelled just because they wanted
to have me booked thinking it would keep
my morning tide up and then just kind of
[ __ ] me by canceling me that's what I
thought at the moment just because of
the old Mancow rival yeah yeah I'm like
they probably do that on purpose and she
was no they didn't I'm like of course
they did and then the day before they
can sue me whatever but it didn't hurt
us because we already had this stuff
before so I'm in the building it turns
out was the same building as him I
walked by his studio once he's on the
air and he didn't see me and I'm doing
this stuff and then at the end of it I'm
ready to leave and his producer comes
over because you want to stop in do you
want to come in like I I guess they
didn't do it for any bad reasons they
didn't do it to [ __ ] me I guess that
they just don't like hey hope you know
Anthony we don't want to have anybody
from ona and I went in and it was I
figured was gonna be confrontational
sano man count from way back before I
knew our day I knew him so I walk in and
uh it looked like it might have been and
we talked for a Cohen was this last week
two weeks go I just forgot to talk about
it no but it wasn't uh it wasn't awful
well what was it I mean it was just me
disgust
seeing what it kind of happened and he
was okay I mean I get I know I'm for for
quite a while he was fine when I walked
in I mean it's nothing I don't know if
it's worth playing wasn't
confrontational no it started off like
yeah he was like I forget what he said
to be honest with you mm-hmm
but I thought it was gonna be kind of
aggressive and we were for a second but
it was not it about it being fun but you
did address it oh yeah I wouldn't want
to go in if I didn't address it I didn't
think he'd want me and if he didn't
address it
Anthony trying to know it we didn't get
that specific but I would have and
anything that they wanted to talk about
I would have talked about yeah you enjoy
the show yeah it was fun mm-hmm I was
fun was turd there he was actually but I
didn't know which one he was until I was
walking out did you ant you should have
asked anyone favored I because I was
expecting it to be very I was expecting
to be confrontational but it was it was
just minor very minor it was oh it's
actually fun I don't want to watch my
back you know it hurts in there I don't
know which ones turd is I never he does
all kinds of crazy pranks going into
those studios that we've had issues with
I never among lexing Terry I did radios
yeah most of them yeah are they here
all right let's just bring him in okay
ah and what you guys got okay okay okay
okay
you're tried trying for and then we're
live on this yeah hi Sam hi Joe there's
Sam Morelle and Joe man key you got here
first right oh yeah
so what's up guys what do you got hey
doing man good it's good to just saw
just I start we're still reeling from
that still reeling do you like it no I
did not really you call it the last gen
I it might be the last time they get my
money at the theater what from that I
mean these people that are better rating
every Star Wars movie online how
infuriating is that everything everybody
just on Facebook my new updated Star
Wars uh listings in order you're like
huh do something productive with your
[ __ ] life well at least they wrote it
I hate it when people post news stories
on Facebook I have access to news
websites like that's supposed to be for
your stuff on Facebook you didn't write
that
some person at CNN wrote it and kids
today do nothing and we're gonna all
right guys what do you got two comics
together you're going to find something
especially guys that do their [ __ ]
podcast together have you had to do that
if there been shows when you actually go
on and like that happens in real life
where they're like okay well these guys
are here to do our show for us so what
do you got and you're like seriously the
worst though is really go the worst is
when they go off your bio and they pull
[ __ ] out you like what do you [ __ ]
think that is a father for like I've had
guys walks I was born in Bayonne and
I'll walk in and I've had guys go up so
you're are you're from Bayonne really
where do I go with that like what do you
think I've built eight minutes my
mother's come to that part of New Jersey
and the worst part is the arrogance like
do you know they think they're Carson
too with that setup yeah that's you you
were an intern on a show yeah I got
nothing like that I understand you
started 1990 my show open it up and let
the comics be the comics you know you're
not always like I'm a big stern guy so
let me just handle this here in Syracuse
and I don't mind those shows I don't
mind those shows I have a lot of people
in them a lot of people hit like when
you walk in as a stand-up and you're
doing like when there's six people in a
room it's usually gonna be decent
because there's enough people to play
off of
right so it's almost like doing a small
crowd like I was telling him Adam and
cow before like I had a good because
again there's a bunch of people bobbing
sounds a shitload of people so it's kind
of hard usually do that we used to have
trouble with who were great [ __ ]
Preston and Steve in Philly
mmm our show used to fight with them a
lot and then I went up a doing it and uh
you know it was like [ __ ] eight
people plus an audience it was [ __ ]
excellent
cuz you have all those people have a
studio audience they did that day
there's just some friends likes or some
ok just people did quite 12 people in
the room whatever it was [ __ ] great
cuz you have a lot of people yeah yeah
it makes things easy yeah this would you
walk in there's just two of them they
can be rough and if they're like this
guys cut into my dumb criminal time you
know where they read that was dumb
you're interrupting my Florida news
second yeah
why did you like Star Wars I haven't
seen it yet did you see you saw you
liked it right I didn't see you sir oh
you know but it's it's getting the very
mixed travis liked it but Travis I mean
whatever whatever Disney shits out and
puts a Star Wars logo on Travis will
approve you know if you like characters
that they develop and then suddenly to
have no part in the story anymore or
characters that you knew from the past
that suddenly don't act like they're
that character even though they're
played by the same actor if there's just
no continuity so what happens if from
the past to the JJ Abrams one no he
didn't Johnson did this with a guy who
did like brick and he's a really good
director
Liat looper great movie I never saw
looper oh it's awesome
who's about somebody who works in the
movie industry right okay yeah it's like
they take familiar characters and just
created a new sci-fi movie out of it
yeah it's just like Mark Hamill was
playing Luke Skywalker but without
giving anything away Luke Skywalker
doesn't act like Luke Skywalker but he's
old does he act like grumpy old Luke
Skywalker no yes
he acts like kind of like a bumbling
idiot is he Luke Skywalker with a
[ __ ] swollen prostate who's late 50s
yes you have to pee a lot I mean there
was that was an odd choice for Star Wars
is Darth Vader in it no he's not Oh suck
my dick
Star Wars well I don't want to see it
without Darth Vader 345 it's after yeah
I don't sequel give a [ __ ] Luke take
this mask off me you know remember that
I all of it I don't want a maid The
Godfather for and brought back Brando
for it well you
understandable if if Brando and sunny
blow up a planet together but since that
you can do whatever you want in this
[ __ ] franchise bring back Vader Jar Jar
Binks developed technology to bring back
villains and holy show that would have
been awesome if charger was in it that
[ __ ] franchise can suck my dick [ __ ]
you because of Darth Vader on he's the
best bad guy in movie history if he's
not in the movie your [ __ ] movie
stinks we'll remember when he threw the
movies
no the one with JJ was [ __ ] great
there was an in it he was he was in it
briefly no wait which one which one was
he in briefly the one one row blurred
over directed that broken was great yeah
that was really good
yeah how do you do another one like that
cuz of dark no but his scene was great
that was why this is why people hate the
new Star Wars because Darth Vader no
because it's it's not what they wanted
where do they want a good movie how
about just a [ __ ] nice something like
rogue one something that's actually a
really good movie and stop with these
[ __ ] cornball do any cornball kids
[ __ ] toy cara noodles but they make
so many bad jokes in the movie it's well
I was talking about it with Sean
Donnelly at the cellar it's every movie
wants to be Iron Man now where the
characters are making all these wacky -
you know router the other one where they
have to be like a little too clever and
you like to shut up and be a movie yeah
yeah just be a superhero put your
[ __ ] cape on and save a baby from
being run over by a truck it's like
these guys superheroes are all dorks and
all of a sudden when they have their
superpowers they're like really quick
off-the-cuff these great lines snazzy
didn't I say that they had little like
fur ball creature fur be looking he
wasn't in it as much as the marketing
campaign would suggest more than that
funny part in the whole movie but then
they went too far by
well I don't want to give it away now
don't tell me about Luke Skywalker he's
an idiot now he's a bumbling fool I
would have thought that he learns the
force at a fairly young age right we
mastered it old for learning the force
but young
compared to like about 40 years ago like
a grad student like 40 years ago you
learned the force forty years ago yeah
who's there 40 years to practice already
knowing the force already knowing the
force and having life you know life
experiences that trip to to you know
Mexico in college you know they the the
first wife and the divorce is why is he
such a fool they it doesn't make any
sense
Travis wives Luke Skywalker an idiot I
disagree with you I don't think he's an
idiot you don't think he's a bumbling
buffoon no and I don't know how much I
want to talk about before Jim sees it
I'll see it over the break I really
wanted someone to see it to finish Star
Wars is probably an annoying Howard lay
his teeth Anthony was in yesterday and
he said that her dentures are
distracting I didn't notice that it's
it's a heavily it's a heavily Leia Leia
based film but it's just what we needed
why don't you like that no [ __ ] cares
how can you sit there and be like you
need more Darth Vader
what do you mean Princess Leia is in it
because the difference that's exactly
what's that who wanted what do you ask
you 10,000 people have seen Star Wars
who do you want to see more of a movie
full of characters in sci-fi history you
know he is but that was back then when
she was [ __ ] young I love you I know
that's what we want nobody wants to see
60-year old [ __ ] Leia did she work
everyone knows she died on a [ __ ] Air
France flight or whatever princess even
though the pan she's from blew up that's
true Air France Carrie Fisher died in
real life but he can get past the fact
that Darth Vader died in the movie or
I'm only saying what do people I love
Terry Fisher she was amazing in that
though she is a great character yeah but
as you get older and that they're doing
this the one you want to see you know
why cuz you can't tell Darth Vader his
age you know why cuz he has a [ __ ]
hat a mask on but meaning in real life
you can hear it in James Earl Jones's
voice Marc [ __ ] Hamill
Harrison Ford but you can see that all
them are so much older so it's not the
same okay Joe you're kind of like this I
know he's dead
fix it complaining about how they're
just doing the same thing well how about
a bad guy that doesn't suck like that
[ __ ] emotionally distraught little
[ __ ] the last time I got dad issues it's
like that guy from girls he's great he's
great he's a good character boy he lose
to this girl that's been practicing the
force for 22 minutes that's a laugh
exactly yeah it make any sense in the
wolf dunk all the other movies we
learned how hard it is to learn the
force and and and Finn scores a hit on a
sip when he's got no practice it's clear
that you think we just lost a lot of
female listeners right there it's clear
that you're in touch with the Star Wars
community I've got my finger on the
pulse right which is important dude sure
should be the trigger is what the Star
Wars community wants in the new Star
Wars movie less Princess Leia more darth
vader is that the problem no I just
think we want a story that makes sense
as a standalone movie and as part of the
history and there's a whole bunch of
moments in the first two in the force
awakens in the last Jedi where you're
like this doesn't make any sense in this
movie because nothing's explained or or
with what happened in the previous six
movies Travis what do you think of Joe
Mackey right now do you think he's like
okay he's making some good point there's
not in a [ __ ] all right well he's being
a [ __ ] but I don't think in the sense
that it's very difficult to make
hesitation Ewing stories different
writers and different direct yeah you
know because so JJ writes and directs
Episode seven and then they basically
say here you go Ryan what do you think
that in writing keys and now JJ is going
to go pick up what Ryan did and continue
the story show what a terrible idea that
is let why they do it it's also not a
billion-dollar franchise that everybody
loves they turned into the aristocrats
you know it's difficult if JJ had an
idea as to who raised parents were right
you know Ryan got to decide who's raised
who raised parents were O'Shea and I'm
not gonna tell you who they are but I
like the decision I don't care who
raised Pam who the [ __ ] is Ray what if
Darth Vader came out and shoot and he
was like Poe I am also your father
[ __ ] little simpkin my dad made me
smite dad of good issues that guy
[ __ ] ate my ass he was so bad if if
if I'm a Star Wars character I don't
want my kid oh very likely to murder you
with a lightsaber it's a recurring theme
yeah it's true I mean I just don't want
it I've lost interest in because I've
learned to hate George Lucas so much
every time Jim makes a joke Mackie
follows it up with a Star Wars specific
well I don't I was even saying like from
one too sick like from from 3 to 6 not
even from Star Trek from 46 a new hope
to now not one two and 42 take on the
prequels oh man they were not that great
right they weren't that great but at
least they kind of made sense let me and
Christensen have a future in Star Wars
what if Darth Vader came back but it was
Hayden Christensen dude here's the thing
it's all James are all it's all David
Prowse and his James Earl Jones James
Earl Jones when he did the DIA the the
rogue one you could hear that they used
his voice and he's piñata is old now it
sounded slightly older like they
probably should have gotten someone who
just did a great Darth Vader oh my god
can you imagine the uproar but I mean if
you Jones is alive you could have got
someone else but it still worked but I
threw me a little bit cuz you didn't
have quite the power in his voice but
that scene where he's walking through
just chopping everybody's [ __ ] head
they go amazing the best part of that
[ __ ] movie is him walking through the
lightsaber go telling everything go [ __ ]
their mothers that was the best part of
that movie that was the first time I'd
been I thought a Star Wars movie had a
scary scene in it
cuz even with the the Yoda lightsaber
battle all machine in those amazing
fighting these fighting Count Dooku and
later Darth Sidious he's going all over
the place it just was this is just CGI
crap no one's scared of yoga yes sir
what if Darth Vader took his helmet off
and Darth Maul was under it would that
be cool
that'd have been cool cuz I thought that
was a character that like in the past
been called Darth Maul ooh
molls a scary name he looked cool and
then he's like he was the guy with the
two lightsabers yes oh goodness
enjoy chip erson [ __ ] stupid but then
he sucked in a movie right well they
just didn't have enough he was cool in
the five seconds that they use on
merrily in the movie yeah then he's done
that was disappointing did Darth Maul
stuff yeah well what's better Joe Mackey
episode 3 which is called what episode 3
is Revenge of the Sith I thought I liked
them is rivetti a that's that's actually
yeah far by far the best of the three
right yeah so is Revenge of the Sith
better than this one that's out right
now oh I think so definitely
whoa hot cake when Star Wars can just
[ __ ] kill itself what if darth vader
comes back I just don't want the JJ did
a good job or whoever did I saw a rogue
one directed it did a great job
Edwards yeah why not just let that guy
thing I know killer more one's a little
easier because it's a whole new story
you're not like there's no expectation
fair enough and it's a story that you
know happened and I know I not a man but
that's easy but you also you're also
very limited when you do that too as to
what your characters can do what you
mean you can do it every day want know
because you have to [ __ ] get people
that are believable as the characters
before you yeah I think it's a I think
you have to tie in with the story I
think it's a it's a harder story or just
as hard to tell I mean when you're doing
episode what is this
10 no 9 10 that was technically it was
episode 8
that you just cuz return the Jedi is six
so the force awakens is seven eight yeah
even though the prequel is before it's
like I don't hate it though I think they
do the original was an amazing Empire
Strikes Back is one of the [ __ ] best
like you know uh sci-fi films ever very
poorly when it came out Return of the
Jedi was okay had all the Ewoks run
around sort of the real [ __ ] he's
starting off the real [ __ ] with
shinless [ __ ] marketing jizz bag yeah
they don't [ __ ] makes [ __ ] na Han
Solo shoot second you know I did it and
then they added more creatures planet of
intelligent teddy bears helped save the
world
yeah so they they took out a lot of that
but Darth Vader is [ __ ] killer who
doesn't like Darth that music I know
fix it they also zap the planet fix it
you know I bet when when Darth Vader's
through the Emperor into that chasm
bring the Emperor was probably like why
did I put this chasm in my room but the
emperor was also a good guy just kidding
yeah JK JK just something better a lot
of what they've given it yeah giving us
a very vicious bad guy this last peg guy
was good he turned him to be a fruit a
lot of it killed Han Solo big deal
spoiler alert a lot of people is he a
lot of people are pissed though about
this one I've heard I'm Joe's not not
really no unique in his opinion a lot of
people like who are big Star Wars fans
are like this makes no [ __ ] sense
what I'm watching right now it is very
split down the middle so then Travis why
do you are you Star Wars apologist or do
you see merit that other people I don't
sit there and say like oh yeah the
prequels are great I just thought this
is a very good movie it didn't want you
to like it the force awakens want to
like it
robos wanted you to like a duplicate it
to the audience and I like what kind of
idiot makes a movie that does that my
strategy when me my contribution to this
show by the way everybody who's out
there I don't want you guys to like me
you're gonna like Sam's our special JJ
made a movie with the force awakens that
was like you know really a really really
really great fanboy movie it's a carbon
copy of a new hope but everybody was
fine with that and I'm fine with that I
thought it was great
no Darth Vader true no Darth Vader Oh
kylo Ren kylo Ren the darkside just
wanted dead yeah the force I like that
there's a conflicted you know
emotionally unstable kid that's trying
to learn is yes that's what we need a
millennial bad guy it's awful he finally
did something in an Ewok blocked up and
get upset I just like you've been there
at the at the first order planning
meeting where they're like we're gonna
build another giant sphere and like why
hasn't that worked out poorly for us in
the past and they're like no no this
time is gonna be different
there's no way that this giant circle is
gonna explode Matt he's got like an
observational chunk on every Star Wars
is that what you know seeing the first
order is the group is the bad guys
they're the bad guys
I understand oh there's a kylo Ren one
is dead 201 acceptance we can really we
can relate to that's what I didn't need
I didn't need that [ __ ] that awkward
meeting at the center of the chasm they
always have walkways over the center
they really yeah you're right they
always do how about you meet so much in
a conference table yeah coffee shop yeah
annoyed me a lot kylo ren's name annoyed
me and I hated the way they Grande kylo
ren's name not just a [ __ ] cool name
kylo Ren 1977 it worked I'm sorry and it
worked
you know kylo does sound like a little
too sir for you [ __ ] new you know Oh
ash
Berber Ashton or some man stinks I want
the old ones back could be obi-wan he's
dead too exactly they kill him
immediately then to the first one such a
good character that oh great and and and
when he was like old if you strike me
down I'll become more powerful I'm like
no if you kill Darth Vader you'll be
pretty inspire people yeah if you strip
me down become more powerful that you
just disappeared yeah you're gone
I mean who cast peter cushing it was
just such a great casting just a good
film the first one mm-hmm but you're
also you're also younger when I was a
boy boys I think you might be
romanticizing it but no it's not what it
used to be in the [ __ ] you know the
little ditty the [ __ ] dumb noises are
to me 13 years before cell phone call
was ever made so when the guy with the
eyes popping up and he goes my friend
doesn't like you that whole cantina
scene shootin chopped out that [ __ ]
music I've talked about 2 minutes I've
hated it elephant playing the trumpet
George Lucas really annoys me but they
got to go there because otherwise how
are they gonna find Han Solo I wonder if
that was a Glac tick cover band too cool
in the gang
is a fun song no I don't and that
elephant that played it I've never hated
the character more than a [ __ ] little
elephant who's playing his thing cuz
they thought that'd be so cute I think
it's great I'm gonna leave it on for the
next two minutes oh my god I hate I hate
this you do hate it you like this Joe
you might start my same stand-up stats
to this angry it's so bad
Boba Fett was a cool character he's
really people over ate the [ __ ] out of
him yeah they do
I mean looks badass
yeah but it was cool cuz he's kind of
[ __ ] kidnapped you and smothered
you're in [ __ ] frozen [ __ ] and took
you away yeah
I'm viola I hated sorry I hated the way
they took out the [ __ ] older fat
started Darth and replaced him with the
younger handsome one that was Lucas was
I do him want something to jerk off to
it was Saul aggravating I can't speak to
that last comment but it was frustrating
you just check out this older guy who
was in the movie and that was the guy
you chose to play him and then you get
the younger handsome one you [ __ ]
fruit stop it neither twink Darth you
think that's what the fans need maybe
just wanting something the chicks could
relate to [ __ ] him yes I love how with
Boba Fett even the Empire hates bounty
hunters but what we use them uses them
like the cut America like dog like dog
bounty Edward that's why we like dog the
Empire well the Empire hires Boba Fett
remember when there's all the bounty
hunters on the Star Destroyer I know I
know but I thought you'd ever that's not
the name you used for them when you said
that they were building the Death Star
the first order in Episode seven they're
the first order cuz the Empire's
destroyed I understand yeah
yup keep up guys yeah pretty cool Nico
was gone Nico well now that he's here
Nico sit down I'm not even trying to I
just I just well he walked in I'm like
what is he here to shoot us [ __ ] came
back [ __ ] came back for a day because
he's got a surprise for us also did you
know Norwich one of my County gets weird
did you know what we did you keep up on
what was going on at all when you were
in Europe oh yeah did you hear about
what Nico's doing no Nico you've said
well we had me going last Thursday on
his last day and he was like yeah
because he came over to me and he goes
uh you want to see something you know I
know this is our accident or Nico and I
was like yeah sure and he showed me his
phone I didn't know what was gonna be on
it and it was a trip planner and he
bought tickets to Las Vegas I did here
because he's going he's going with Mary
Jean to the AVN's Mary Jean actually
told me yeah
Mary Jean actually texted me told me yes
she did tell me that he's gonna be your
suitcase pimp I think while she's out
there cuz he's got a follower to the
signings and all this that's [ __ ]
great
yeah Niko comment are you looking
forward to this yes did the boys work on
your press pass yeah not as far as I
know you got him you done alright the
porn Awards I know best it's actually
I've hosted it twice that it used to be
it's not as big as it used to be because
of all the online stuff and it's just a
different business but it used to be
when I hosted one year it was like 6,000
people attended and one year 7,000 all
the porn stars in the world and a huge
audience behind and you go up be to a
few jokes and then you [ __ ] they
start having that the stars come out and
present awards best anal best come sure
they have all of them and it's a real
show man they name it had at the end you
a pretty big music like the year I did a
one-year I did it was like Little John
and whoever else these side boys
I don't remember a Twins might I don't
remember him in somebody else is there a
Razzies equivalent our friend Mary Jean
is nominated for viewers Choice titties
her tits are [ __ ] spectacular and
Nico is gonna is gonna go with her and
Nico is a virgin do you hear that money
whenever that tomb like gets turned on
it [ __ ] everything's not good it
stinks yep yeah but Nico is gonna go
with her and he's a virgin and Nico has
said he will not be happy or satisfied
unless by the time he has left Las Vegas
he at least has gotten a [ __ ] no let
me ask you Nico do you have to have it
from Mary Jean or did you take it for
anybody I'll take it from any female no
I of course have you know would you be
happy just if she just put her heinie in
your face do you get to masturbate we
should we were strategizing with him a
little bit and the consensus is that the
best possible idea is not for him to be
intimate with Mary Jean but to get Mary
Jean to bring some friends in yeah
for those to be the one you deflower
neko like in a like in almost famous did
you have to buy the tickets yeah I know
how much we just talked a little how
much were they altogether cost me 600
see you in marriage ena gonna coach yes
she's okay with that yes cool tell her
six hours earlier because she tends to
get their last minute you get your own
separate tickets with your own names on
it right yes okay cool
yeah because what airline doesn't know
who cares I know why myself I caught
myself but yes so he's uh he's going out
there wow that's great and that's
another buck saved up I had the money
for the clip for you
that's of his own boobs for Nico nobody
pushed him to do it and he's not even an
intern when he's going out I did I did
that's right you're going out there just
as a man as it you know as a young no
college credit right he's not getting
college credit for this one
alright well cook now he's also the
reason he's in though yeah does it I
would have waited for you to talk about
this but I was like oh it's his last day
on Thursday so I gotta talk about this
sure of course and then after the show
he was like he was talking to Travis and
he was like yeah he goes I've uh I have
something for the for the guys so can I
can I come in next week and I'm like
yeah today we just announced everybody
today was your last day but I guess you
can come in in four days that's fine so
by the way you're gonna love the x-bow
and what are you going to dare to early
we're leaving the 23rd Jim do you get
nervous when your friends are about to
fly sometimes I do because it smells
like you've gotten a little nervous
talking bearish me no one else noticed I
did not notice okay go like this
everybody together one two three it's
nothing I got nothing so uh you got
anything I heard it though okay so you
know it's coming so I don't know why and
breathe in
not a good suggest so you go to the expo
do when you walk around the expo floor I
think they have all day like that people
are doing signings and stuff you'll
enjoy them cuz you did some hot girls
they're [ __ ] little fat ass you're
gonna enjoy that a lot Nikko however
introduce you to people could Mary Jean
pine knows a lot of people there if you
probably be fun to do like a like a
three-day weekend there right yeah he's
doing like six days oh you're gonna be
[ __ ] girl by the time six days and
he's following Mary Jean around the
whole time I'm like what's your schedule
and he's like I'm waiting Mary Jean
she's gonna tell me what the schedule is
and I'm just gonna follow her for six
you'll probably have followed her though
I knew probably she's crazy and she
knows everybody and she's funny and
she's chats with everybody like she's
very personable so you have a good time
with her
I hope there's an orgy young great would
that be if there was an orange never a
bad thing but for a little me oh my god
and he gets yelled at cuz he's tiptoeing
through and he puts his toenail on
someone's balls he Clips their bag like
a velociraptor can you imagine going
from I can't shut the doors in my house
so I have to masturbate in the bathroom
while I'm pretending to [ __ ] - I just
had to orgy with a bunch of porn star
it's all I want for him isn't it great
yeah I want this young virile man yeah
to come back deflower and he's going on
his own it's not as an Internet which is
great yeah whatever happens happens yeah
he's just going this is how he wanted to
spend his fun break from his - and then
he's coming back by the way so so he's
going to Vegas right and he's there
until the 28th of January yes the first
day of his second semester of his
internship is January 29th we shouldn't
talk about what he comes back though
yeah that's the orientation that's
that's Nico that's it that's his I don't
think we should talk about that me
neither it's personal a lot of a lot of
that that sort of sexual stuff is very
personal
yeah it's is that I don't you know I
know people are interested what is the
date you're going out there 23rd that's
great and you're coming out to the 30th
or 29th we're coming back to 28th in
that afternoon when is the actual Awards
27 all right okay you think Nico's gonna
gonna have a great time
yep I do too for the first couple days
it'll be quiet to be a few things but
the 27th is a Saturday so the twenty
sixth twenty fifth twenty four three
felt like dialed kind of heat up with
the Expo I hear it's not against not
what it used to because there's just not
as many people going to it but I also
good luck for what's up for Best Picture
this year at the avian I don't know you
they usually it used to be like I fed
the fashionistas I think it was called
the year I went that was a huge one I
want to say belladonna was in that
mermaid that movie pirates that was like
the big porno movie do their big
whenever you take off I want and it's
almost shot like a real [ __ ] like
like a high production a high budget
film this was a John staliano movie with
the fashionistas I think it was called I
don't remember but Niko going out there
the timings good because he'll have like
a couple of days is that this year Lil
Wayne Oh young wheezy is gonna be out
there Lynch they always have a real a
real a real music guest Oh tune she's
going getting Eagles gonna have two days
to get comfortable right - that's right
sort of like I'm here in Vegas this is
so weird I'm not you don't have those
two days get it out of his system and by
the third day this would be comfortable
it'll be like a second home and then
he'll be able to you know get that dick
wet you know that's what I felt
yeah have you been to Vegas he hasn't
been on a plane three years old it's a
fun place just to walk around you guys
do dig there no nobody there you know
you've been it up been there yeah but
he's never traveled Quint it's a fun all
right yeah you'll be great just go ahead
we're a little early that's my advice
just go Holly that should be easy with
Mary Jean there just to get her early to
places well yeah she tends to be you
know if you're gonna hear her say this a
lot early bird gets the worm yep she
says if you if you're on time you're
late
that's an old Mary Jean Ann yes yeah we
sometimes we call the club soda Mary
Jean because she's always so early
although they were trying to they're
trying to save some money and Miko
pointed out to Mary Jean you know it's
cheaper if you buy tickets for a morning
flight and so you got to get to the
morning flight yes first first flight 11
o'clock
Mary Jean didn't want to go on the more
she insisted 11 o'clock I'm like Mary
Jean it's like $200 at 11 o'clock
tell her it's a red-eye so you got to
get there at midnight wait so she wanted
to go at 11
here's why she was wrong and I should
think of this because the traffic when
you're going to the airport at 11 is an
abomination because you're leaving at
8:00
you're sitting in a rush-hour traffic to
get there so even though you got to get
up earlier if you're flying at 8 it
means you're leaving at 5:30 or whatever
your [ __ ] find Mary Jean is not
leaving at 5:30 for an 8 o'clock flight
that might happen but maybe you ought to
do this spring for a hotel room at the
airport the night before
maybe you guys just go the night before
and stay at hotel should suggest that to
her
you know what then you get you get an
extra night no hotel with Mary Jean
right are you guys staying in the same
room yes oh my couple of beds just for
your own privacy and right her privacy
and then you figure it out when you get
there two beds two beds and then figure
it out after that all right we are back
I think I got everybody which is a Jo
did you have a question about poi go box
what's that Jim and Sam one word or Jim
and Sam one where all is the
advertisement him okay Sam is okay hi
Dave eat that Mike that [ __ ] Mike
they've never fixed it's just shitty
it's okay better yeah much much better
did I did a little bird tell me you guys
are talking about the new Star Wars
movie we were big fans how was it on a
scale of 1 to yon Josh got some serious
serious issues with it none of the rest
of us have seen it it was it was a yawn
no but what about what another win for
Mark Hamill all right he said Mark
Hamill was a goof in it yeah yeah they
said he hasn't been this good since
Corvette summer Corvette summer like
Netflix money like 20 million that's
what I heard really yeah
to get him back into it well but like
you know hey we gotta start paying him
like you know Harrison Ford money his
agents a real actor by the way Harrison
Ford made [ __ ] millions it had this
like amazing career and then in Luke
Skywalker and Hamill just did nothing
the big red one I mean I've haven't Matt
that summer was a great summer argue he
did a lot of theater in between these
movies he was huge as the voice of the
Joker I'm
oh yeah yeah yeah that was a big deal
for him but Han Solo like he was Harris
before it's a cool dude yeah
chicks dig him you know they like Luke
Skywalker to know they didn't quit who's
boyish yeah tonight like some very
different opinions he lives is a hunk of
[ __ ]
someone on Twitter called me the voice
of Star Wars in a condescending way and
I'm like I don't give myself that
nickname thank you that's the worst
thing they said to you on Twitter if
you're the voice of complaint was the
future it's two episodes after turned
the Jedi okay it's a sequel which robots
are in it c-3po is in it r2d2 is in it
all good and the circle okay
the circle wit it like pea seed now is
it like a gender-neutral r2h this is a
whole the oil for Jabba the Hutt
I never was into the Star Wars thing I
like the first one and the second one
there's a couple of my like than the
other what the other ones made i filled
me with rage the first one was very dark
it was really you know it was more of an
adult movie now and now it seems like
it's a you know it's like something you
watch when you've got a you know camp or
something right yeah if he went to a
cool camp the first ones weren't that
dark II like the first ones were dark
like if you're a kid and you watch them
you're like oh this is I'm serious [ __ ]
well there was a whole planet of people
killed which was kind of good yeah yeah
they did blow a whole planet up they did
kill thee and everyone the rebel star it
wasn't a dark movie though if you go
back and watch it as an adult it's still
just as silly as anything Darth Vader
killed [ __ ] Oh Blin can all be puts a
[ __ ] sword through him yeah I mean
the Han Solo died in the one two years
ago he's old yes all right I'm Way
behind so who do you think you relate to
you the most in the you know I get Lando
Calrissian a lot
I thought Lindo got there through
earning it loud city that's a pretty
good resume Cloud City
speaking of bitcoins Jimmy yeah my
garden I guy I actually got I got a
thousand of them in the beginning Wow
into what the value is no I don't I
don't pay attention to stock okay well I
just kind of come in and do my thing let
accountant handle it oh you should head
up to the other you know middle level
comics dude I forgot I had I forgot I
had a big stock big coin yeah that's
probably pushing a pie pushing like 300
a share give one to your doorman for
Christmas Thanks do you tip them all I
had to give the tips morning oh yeah how
many are in your building I don't have
like nine might be smaller that's not
that bad I used to have like 25 in my
old building I know I remember that
building maintenance guys and [ __ ]
pool people yeah and I bet you you're
good you're you're not like a cheapo
no I'm not I do it because they don't
you know then they they treat you good
all year so don't [ __ ] with them right
but you know that a my building there's
older folk who I think just baked them
things oh yeah here's a nice Oh like
waste of time yeah nobody wants that
they think it's like like we live on a
farm or something you know did you move
no not yet
are you still thinking of it I don't
know what the tax code the way it is
this is adult stuff sorry laughs yeah I
don't know what I should do but uh yeah
I definitely want to move on to
something because uh have you guys
talked about the tax code here no we
were gonna save it until like your
Gilberts coming until we figure we make
it a whole life all yeah things have a
Rainman quality remember what he dropped
the toothpicks how amazing he was that
he counted them all huh yeah yeah we got
to talk about Gilbert when he comes in
about his documentary did you see it Jim
I did yeah this is why I was cut out of
it you were yeah but I think the second
time you've been cut out of a movie
second I feel only once I haven't been
but it's like when in real life I I did
I don't care I'm not mad at Gilbert cuz
he didn't but the director could have
called me and told me
what you get and tell you what were you
just doing any of your comments not and
I'm okay with that but just let me know
and the director didn't let the [ __ ]
director she go there premiere yes you
just sat there looking at the screen
like a [ __ ] were you sitting there
thinking like I was saying I saw one of
the guys from F Troop Larry Stewart at
what point when you're when you're
watching this premiere and you're
sitting next to Larry Storch and you're
staring up at the big screen do you
realize I don't think I'm gonna be in
this movie 20 but when they start going
to and three times back to the center
they've already talked right you like
all of a sudden like just Jeff Ross's
eighth comment are you lying you said 11
things and I'm like yeah no I probably
didn't say anything valuable yeah maybe
they just lost all the Jim Norton
footage I just again that happens
sometimes but at least let me know yeah
I could see that yeah so the director I
would I [ __ ] hope he dies in a fire
but Gilbert who's actually very good and
he'd give us a really interesting guy
he is you know he's going on again which
is great and it's it's very
family-friendly I guess we could talk to
him here is take about it but this is a
great lineup can I say that I haven't
been in a while and I'm working with Joe
and Sam at Caroline's coming up so what
is that tonight or tomorrow and Thursday
no no it's next it's like two weeks from
now right no next start the 26 ok the 26
through up to the day before yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be rocking shell 2 1
2 7 5 7 4104 you don't have tickets yet
that's it [ __ ] an amazing show Joe
and salmon of course I tell new years
these guys are really you know it's
gonna be it's gonna be rough for me
because they're really strong and Sam
just shot is a did he talk I saw an
Amy's Instagram I forgot you did you
produce your specially directed
yeah yeah yeah where'd you shoot how
many shows to show cool honey call when
well first show was good second show was
uh was even better they were really hot
everyone says this the second show is
always bet Dave what is it this curse of
the first show I don't know I think
everyone's a little nervous maybe you
know and then you know you still need
that that like last-minute rewrite on
the jokes you know you're like oh I'm
gonna change that and then the second
show you feel like a little bit more
comfortable cuz you've already failed
yeah I see it but these crowds now that
comes to these things some of them are
fans some of them are just you know like
they kind of did like a mass
you know like hey want to go sit inside
somewhere and then these people show up
you know we every director says this
have to f - you do your first shot you
got it next one is gravy they always
tell you that you got it on the first
one like oh no problem and you're like
no I didn't I'm suicidal after the first
one and then the second one I'm like
alright that was that was good
first one was 7:30 - right so it's the
early on a Monday but it's usually
better than you think the first one when
you watch him then pause the first ones
like oh that was oh it didn't it didn't
suck it was okay I think you're doing
like you're also doing you you're
delivering it and then the second one
you really like you're a little too
cocky because the crowd is good so yeah
well that's that no one wants to watch a
comedian that believes in himself you
know they want to see you just
delivering the law 7:30 on a Monday you
could but you booked the venue the day
before how the [ __ ] where was it well
Amy's in Steve Martin's play so she had
to be there and you know that's that's
the night off so Amy introduce you and
then Steve wanna introduce her what
happened with some banjo but do air
quotes you know he's a wild and crazy
guy did you do you want like Jimmy's
just talking about in the Edit when you
start saying like oh that's right that
wasn't as bad as I thought it was do you
did you watch back in the Edit I just
shot us and we're not editing till
January oh I got you watching a little
break yeah watch your own terror [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] a timecode obsessed [ __ ]
literally pulled this joke out of the
Early Show put it in late like I'm
[ __ ] all over to make sure you pay
attention to the time codes and you and
really do it don't let them do it yeah
no I actually been that way to where you
have like you get the transcript and you
read and you're like ah
oh my god I have to find that word you
know it's just so much work yeah I watch
well I buy I bring them both up on the
computer and watch a minute and then a
minute or two minutes and two minutes
and I see what worked better and you can
hear the laughs on each right Jim you're
like how many specials in though a
half-hour and five hours Wow yeah that's
crazy that's good yeah real [ __ ] a
nice lukewarm resume you must be your
only problem I was running out of titles
missiles I need a better one just this
the next one should be called Jim Norton
2018
[Laughter]
running out of titles that's a good
title it is let me ask you this
sure if they had specials in the Star
Wars universe would you go see who would
you pay top dollar for all mates window
I mean he's another guy I'm compared to
a lot Jax yeah
he has a purple lightsaber because he
really gets on both the light and dark
sides of the force hi Steve a bisexual
that's what that is the tribute to
bisexual
Jedi's aren't supposed to get married or
half relations Wow really why why don't
you guys [ __ ] together a run for
Congress well they're supposed to be you
know concentrate on the force and look
and their sense you know to walk the
path you can't have or you don't worldly
distract you can't dump loads oh you can
jerk off I mean you don't need to if you
have the force though how many the force
jerk you off
look I don't I'm not touching my nose
and when you were growing up did you
have another friend you could share this
with maybe yeah maybe a little too
touchy priest yesterday but when you
were in Dublin I was watching your
Instagram video and you accepted a ride
from a stranger on the street oh yeah I
walked out of the hotel and I was
walking in his [ __ ] van stops and
this guy goes uh Jim Norton and I'm like
yeah and he's talking about the Opie and
Anthony show and Jim and Sam and chip
and I'm like I'm looking for this place
to eat and he goes uh-uh there's a plate
I'm like where is it he goes hop in
I just got in a stranger's [ __ ]
you've got in the van Wow come on you it
was weird yeah it's definitely not me I
just got into I didn't film in a bit I
just got in his delivery truck and I sat
with him for a half hour
oh no you traffic like I literally could
have take me three minutes to walk or to
drive it how what venue are we doing
there I did a vicar street is called
have you done it no I don't
I've been there and so long Dublin was
good London was great they're really
good we were gonna do our own European
tour you and me Colin wants to do it too
we should do it
that'll be great I just did it to get
over there I was like [ __ ] it just book
it I want to do it
the availabilities you got a book a year
out like [ __ ] the the what's the one
everybody does in in London
Piccadilly Circus no no not the Soho
Castle I don't know Harrods so high I
remember whatever its junglers oh wait
but it's a year out you got a book it
and did they get yourself or they were
amazing real everything everything all
radio show fans really podcast yeah and
yet a driver out there now - what's that
you got a driver out there now - so
you'd be fine yes I do
invite you home for a good old Irish
meal i buy them to the show he was a
huge mother would you've gone back to
the place if you know no you sure he was
a good guy though it's so weird that you
got in his van I couldn't believe I did
it I just got in and we just drove
there's just your instinct was like okay
yeah that's a great idea yeah why not
yeah he's cool
you were like an ambassador for our land
yeah he was a good guy I could sense he
gets sent to use it out he's not a deck
you as a fan of the show and he knew all
the radio stuff right yeah by the way
when you're saying like I don't think
that that guy is a bad person he's a fan
of the show that's usually not evidence
that they're not a bad no basically no
sign my narcissism I miss Anthony they
all miss Anthony got in the van subjects
what other jokes do you like yeah where
the star a bit but then there's some
criticisms are they really over there
let's hear it I don't remember what they
were a guy you got in the guy's van and
he was giving you credit things that he
liked things that he didn't like but he
wasn't a dick about it I was okay with
it uh-huh
did you just accept a ride from a
stranger get in his van he's like here's
what you could do to change your show up
alone well maybe certain things that the
old elements of the show that it didn't
enjoy that are no longer part of the
show
[Laughter]
not my crowds aren't usually not so I
didn't see I didn't they asked me after
in Manchester the guy said you want to
stop by the Comedy Store but I was like
I had to fly early yeah but if I went on
there that might have been
but they don't you know where they want
my crowd you know how it is when you're
going somewhere they know what you know
the the only guy I know who does England
consider Dan hope does it all the time
yeah they love him over there they do
these are the like they're Bill Hicks
now you know oh okay he's like they're
at the elevated comedy had he was always
telling me how difficult it is like to
you know they want you to bring like a
whole new hour that's how they tour
there with just like they have like this
long hour that they do yeah so it's not
really like jokes there I think it's
more like a long story I guess um you
know for in Ireland noir of a legend you
have to go I did mine I'd stood my act
but that you gotta wait at least a year
to go back I wouldn't go back with a new
year unless I went somewhere else
okay they also in like Edinburgh all the
shows have themes right and it's like
about your feelings that's that really
easy for me Sam sorry to interrupt again
hahaha no just like there's a guy
running on a treadmill and the whole
theme was he was like out running his
demons but he's running the treadmill
the whole show just wants to show that
he can do an hour of cardio and talk
that's pretty impressive
he's like get it guys how about running
my demons and I have treadmill yeah a
one-hour [ __ ] pun and and is that
that's a festival right there's not just
one off that guy won the festival oh he
did yeah he outran everybody well yeah I
guess so I'm but he's really talking
while these runners you walking on it I
don't know I didn't I didn't ask that
many follow-up question is next year has
to do it on a exercise bike it's gonna
be different it's gonna come up gonna be
different no I thought like as the act
progresses like the trail goes up higher
and higher more demons stands around a
bunch of condiments and goes I'm trying
to catch up well I wonder what the
endorsements are alone for that that
must be awesome just all the you know
everything he wears you know you should
be able to like write that off of course
like an athlete right yeah and you know
that's what I love about how
international comedy is see like over
here people would probably see that and
go like yeah but over there it's a big
deal it's an applause worthy thing you
go
I really put effort into the pneumatics
Jim what are you thinking Norway should
we hit that or what I would have hit
Norway I've hit
I've hit Amsterdam I've hit Antwerp
Belgium I think two of the cities I was
with what was the third and Dachau I did
not say I wanted to go there the great
places it was normally Antwerp and
Denmark and Stockholm I hit five cities
in the night this time I just hit London
in that channel from city to city
problem is it's a [ __ ] day in and out
you don't have time to do anything
you're in and out a day right so it's
fun it's kind of shitty because you're
in and out so fast like this time it was
like I actually paid a guy a lot of
money to drive me from London to
Manchester coz I couldn't wake up and do
another flight alright let's travel yeah
let's do a two-week thing we relax we
hang out like we used to do yeah well I
thought it was trains I get don't they
do trains over there did we do trench
there you go yeah trains we could bring
a backgammon set yeah afternoon flyer
and I'm more of a morning flight which I
think that's the whole thing the
juxtaposition is nuts I should be a fern
cried out you remember that was my
nickname first flight out right no thank
you Nick named it was like first flight
out and then child rapist just know the
point of it is this you know in Europe
you know we can be there together and we
can kind of barometer how much they hate
us what I'm saying yeah
is America all dressed up as a cowboy
and you could be a guy in oil rig the
Native American sure you could go
between England and France to take that
tunnel oh that would be awesome right
you know I wins in the tunnel yeah I
love to swim my favourite swim how long
does it take to get on a train in the
tunnel I do want to do that I didn't you
didn't time train is I know that to
drive it it's like I'd probably take the
train a couple hours I try to take the
train you can take a boat you could get
on the ferry between England and France
that might be fun
yeah how does that take a couple hours
two hours make an afternoon leave you
off on the beach like you know like
Norman Norman
like a quarter-mile out yeah but walk it
in yep and there's all this big like
Jagga Texas and you should make it
afternoon of it you they I think so how
about this we set up one we do a little
something in Paris maybe just to try it
right and then we take the ferry over
and we get some material you're going oh
you get material on the fair yeah yeah
I'll say hey you can do anything about
how long token you go no but you do how
windy it was we'll just kind of split up
the joke that's so great actually
yeah I love getting inside the mind of a
comedian ya know it's fascinating really
analyzing where jokes are made me well I
would rather you closed the show but we
can actually go out there and flip one
of your big coins and then like we both
see it but they don't and they love that
kind of stuff they'll be like oh ow
I picked heads that was the worst part
of torment that nobody wants to want
after day that's just you know that's
just truth no that's not true it is your
dummy easy follow a thing true you're
not really following I am my stuff is so
corny now it's like God please like ha
no I really am the weakest one there
every night every day actually now that
I did the early shows that the cellar I
see Jim there he's always working on new
stuff to these tourists they look at him
sometimes like what do you think a hero
I know you cheer being self-deprecating
but you two are much better comedians
than Sam he was at the white [ __ ] on the
left no without the thing David are
co-headlining these gigs and it was I
said oh what the years ago oh that was
great so that was with Amy and uh no no
no no I just mean you did a few okay
years ago and the thing was they would I
guess just put the money I'm like I want
Dave to go on last he could take more
money I mean Dave's a [ __ ] was a
really a humble guy you think that we'll
split up I don't want to go on after
Dave and the one time I was gonna go on
after Dave I was like okay I'll do it I
didn't want you know it was Boston at
the Orpheum and you took the wrong route
you took the [ __ ] 95 route right and
it was really it was really late because
he did the GPS just took him the wrong
way instead of three hours took him five
hours so we're at the Orpheum and the
crowd was [ __ ] antsy because it was
like 30 35 minutes late and the
promoters panicking he's like just go on
and I walk on and I'm [ __ ] five
minutes into it I look over and I see
Dave walking onto the side of the stage
they all [ __ ] thank God I was so
happy
no parable story I didn't say it was
great but I'm just saying that I was
respect to Dave didn't do anyone else
well that's nice but I mean the tour we
did with with Amy and Artie and you and
hey do you to do in Stanhope - we do
with me you done and and stand up was I
wanna bill burr Brewer yeah I was a good
shows man damn yeah [ __ ] me you burn
Brewer was the first inclination of that
yeah Artie Lange his first gig back
after two years was with us that was a
great [ __ ] fun tour and a shout out
to Artie I saw him the other day
you know he's trying to get better so
yeah I apologize I punched him in the
face but he's going to rehab which I'm
really happy for awesome he's uh you
know he's [ __ ] the judge said five years
ago to rehab so hopefully it tastes you
know he's just we say yeah it's like
he's not a train wreck he's a [ __ ]
hilarious comic you don't you don't the
best guy I know he really is I mean
honestly he's such a sweetheart and you
don't want to see him just getting
pegged at all right he's already gonna
die it's like alright we get it but he's
really he's a great comic and so
brilliant and it's so Larry and a great
guy everybody loves this guy it's like
alright man just get your [ __ ] together
you know yeah I'm a key and I did a show
like years ago and it was like big deal
for us or you know we we loved already
we you know always and then we go on and
out of the gate Mac he was like I bombed
two shows tonight and already was like
here and where else lovely guy have you
guys lived your bucket list out yeah he
was so nervous to meet Artie that he
vomited in the bathroom I puked because
I was we were gonna do the show and I'm
just super nervous back so he for other
reasons do you get nervous around the
bigger names or I used to not so much
anymore but you know when you're it
conics weird cuz you can you're working
with your heroes pretty quick in where
he is like just like caroline's next
weekend am i right yeah those are gonna
be fun shows I hope Sam's up to the task
I don't think he is
and I'm not gonna throw up because that
bathroom it's kind of a small bathroom
lock doesn't work all the time in the
sink leaks but yeah you want to work
with if you can work with anybody alive
a good question that's a good one right
absolutely great Fatty Arbuckle I've
never worked with nor McDonald that'd be
fine
yeah I know it's great that would be
really good what about you Sam morale
alive or dead alive or dead ooh I don't
know I mean
Bonnie Dangerfield okay Oh respect
thanks for throwing it back to me yeah I
like to work with totie fields she done
kisses first [ __ ] TV appearance I
didn't know that her and Robert Klein it
was the Mike Douglas show and she was
talking about jeans hook knows that he's
Jewish and I would if I could go see one
concert of a Deborah it would be Sam
Kinison I did you know I saw Sam live a
couple of times yeah I didn't I never
got similan just started comedy and he
was working at Rascals south oh cool
what a cool place I was doing open mics
in those days like 1990 and I was
[ __ ] that we would do like you know
the rascals South had that cool showroom
and then the bar area to the open mic
and then one day after the show Ward
brought Sam out to talk to the comedian
so we all get to talk to him for about
ten minutes and he was a little drunk
but he was really sweet MIT was know
what time I got to meet him what year
was that again 1990 Wow I started idea
91 so what was the year like he popped
like it was after that movie with Rodney
Danes wait 80s 89 him and ice around the
same time I want to say could check that
Troy I want to say 88 89 out that
Saturday then he'll album is [ __ ]
crazy
first time he's in the Dangerfield
special he was [ __ ] the second you
saw him he killed it when that fit we
pulled the Mike out of the thing it was
like if you could take your dicks that
you would to your wife you know he could
pull the mic out was such a funny bit
but the way he would start off his
Letterman screaming he just people
anyone who like looks back this younger
people look back and kids who wasn't
that you don't understand how [ __ ]
powerful he was really powerful his
opening line on Letterman was there's
still time to call the church and stop
this they're the greatest
is that the one where he looked nervous
like there's one or two where he was
like nervous like he could tell like he
was like a little nervous but then once
he got into his flow maybe on that one
he was but that was before he was
wearing like even the beret he just had
the hair kind of parted like full all
the way from the side he was still
wearing like the house French codes yeah
I like that I didn't like what he got
real rock and roll after one point where
he started like like you know we're in
the [ __ ] bandana I like to be head
like the little beret when he was it
like an arena comic that's where I lost
when he started doing that yeah that's
where it didn't happen for me yeah for
that I was like wow this guy it was
almost like no one could hold the stage
like that like that's when you look at
that you know it's like that guy really
could hold it that Dangerfield specially
the Dangerfield's young comedians
special dice blew up from Kinnison blew
up arms Chimel
was he yeah and so with Shamu and so I
got my rarer right down the road was
great there was so many that those
lineups
Carolee for was on at those lines first
stack who else was on I know on dice
because dice told the story Barry Sobel
was on here that one - yeah I don't
remember who else was on and then there
[Music]
but yeah Chimel is another guy who I
definitely you know why I got to
actually work yeah and see him live so
he was great - who's yours Norton
yeah do you and want to work with I mean
I wish I would've worked at Richard
Pryor at The Comedy Store I wasn't doing
the store I met him once it was there in
94 I wish me and Patrice actually went
and met him or 95 could follow him you
know that night probably but I I
followed dice the first time I did the
store I was doing the Louie Anderson
show like seven cleamen it's a [ __ ]
stand-up and dice just went on out of
the blue and [ __ ] Frankie pace didn't
want to go on after him frankly so The
Comedy Store the guys clean no it was
surprisingly dirty for an hour
Maureen Tarrant had got me a spot just
to warm up for Louie Anderson the next
night watching then so i [ __ ] uh
nobody wanted to go honest the dice were
so dirty so they [ __ ] you know the
hosts they would say who's going on any
when Jim Norton and dice is like
sex guys grave who is he and he's
[ __ ] on me and I when I and I I knew
I would bomb after him I [ __ ] died
you did one of my heroes I died for
seven minutes but I called Florentine
when dice was on from the pay phone at
the store I guess it on stage so Jim
came and was talking to him offstage
when I came off they were chatting and
that's how I got to know dice but you
didn't win him back at all the audience
know you couldn't get there after too
long story for now me and Jim went back
on later as Jim and Jim and just did
obscure dice lines from the day they
laughter died and we bombed even hard no
was that after the arena Z and that's
mid-90s but he was still doing I toured
with him after that we became friends
and I wound up touring with him and
doing like 3,000 seats 4,000 seats with
the Rosemont and Chicago two nights in a
row he was still doing [ __ ] a lot of
numbers many but he wasn't doing 17,000
but he was dice was still killing them
and the crowd would yell at you like
where's they like there I never bombed
in front of him III had tough shows but
never by almost bombed in Chicago wants
the Rosemont front a four thousand
people they booed me I couldn't hear my
opening line because they were [ __ ]
booing so hard and then somebody heckled
and you know how [ __ ] hecklers are and
I addressed it and they literally
thousand laughed and then one more
person yelled and they all shut up to
hear like the animals want to [ __ ]
Roman wanted to hear what you did and if
I knew if I got on my hat and I wound up
getting and killing the guy and then I
wound up having a decent set that's cool
yeah but that's crazy
I love dude ice was [ __ ] amazing to
work with him because his crowds they
didn't know who I was and they were
[ __ ] animals Wow they taught me a lot
how about you do you guys have a Creek
in the cave story Cody feels for you uh
yeah no I I feel like she of all the
like amazing lady like she's the one
that no one really knows her work you
know she was out of it before like I
guess people were were into it you know
what I'm saying yeah but I read one of
her lines like when they had like like
lines from everyone which I love Joan
Rivers
and everybody does yeah but like this
toady feels like she has a sign like you
know which is just like a classic left
turn joke of like you know I went a two
week diet and all I lost was two weeks
and I was like hey you know it whether
it's good or bad that's like evergreen
joke oh yeah that's cool
not every joke holds up sure you know
and for the amount of laughter she I got
on that read that would be kind of cool
and she lost a leg that's really yeah so
became tawny field Robert Klein for me
was one of my my [ __ ] heroes like I
saw him live a lot I've gotten to know
him and be with him what's that yeah but
every whole text me once in a while like
that's one of my favorite things being a
Santa but I just got to know Robert
Kline's well my favorite people ever
he's he's another guy who's like you
know back in the day like he was a
teacher before he was a comic so like he
had a real job and he like did a real
thing and in a super smart guy and his
uh what's the name of his first special
is like live I don't know Robert I was
the first HBO special I don't really ask
all 75 that was comic special on HBO
yeah that was the one that started
everybody he did I know Robert Klein at
Yale is one of my favorites ever that
was done in like in 82 from from Yale he
was a drama student or Drama graduate I
don't remember what the first ones were
called he was just he's a genius wonder
if we could remaster that with some
counter speech on it what are you
shooting again why are you shooting
another one I'm not ready yet I don't
have the jokes now I don't have enough
jokes and pretty much every joke I have
I'm already rethinking these guys no
these guys are great joke comics today
by the way these guys are great joke
comics Joe and Sam yeah yeah and that's
like the dying art of comedy you know
they're like blacksmiths in the age of
who's on your shirt oh it's the Knicks
rookie I'm sorry something so much good
news so many jokes
Davis is hard his harshest critic by a
mile
yeah thanks thanks mom yeah Joseph I
literally don't enjoy III watch what we
would do the food the [ __ ] gigs
together I would hate watching
back on within five minutes here's
something that was like oh I'll never
write that you never write that joke
it's such a [ __ ] great your joke
about [ __ ] doing having a pillow
fight when you're on acid is one of my
favorite things anyone's ever said oh
yeah well I don't know if that's an
international joke training session in
Iceland what do you think I've never
been there
it's nice I've been there once yeah I
went to bobby fischer's grave are you
doing okay guys let's take it down and
you leave a rook play checkers that is
great come on he wasn't wrong she went
to the museum to he bought a t-shirt
shitty Museum Wow we're gonna crush if
they have no other entertainment yeah I
mean really I'd love to do a gig there
is there a Viking reenactment the museum
was crowded when you went right the
museum hold them there like we'll keep
it open for you no I'm glad I went
he's my boyhood hero on mine I still
love him the Bobby Fischer love for my
favorite again one of my fav I could
meet anybody ever it probably would have
been Bobby Fischer I don't know you're a
master chess player I am I just I love
the art of the I love the art of it
really I love bishoping you do yeah
diagonal well no if I see you next I
just see two bishops crossing Wow oh I
used to see you like with that book
whatever that is it's right chess
mastery oh there you go
we used to play every night at this I'll
take really know every night we would
play mm-hmm and what who'd you play with
keith patrice st would play sometimes
kevin hart would come in and play I just
[ __ ] knew then I mean just all of us
would play everyone Jordan Rubin Wow Oh
Kevin Hart doesn't play chess with you
anymore at the cellar I have to
reintroduce myself I have to stand
behind like a rope but a lot of times
I'll walk over and give me a hug like
yeah we knew each other better with the
rope right there
yeah yeah yeah one of those hugs we have
to lean in your torso yeah it's like a
hill the hill every swing be polite and
Jim is a good friend it was L I said
what Jim was a good friend of mine in
origin we came up together know that
he's polite right it's clear a major
celebrity is polite to you like all
right right Jim this is why you're not
you don't celebrity friends oh I like
when you're with at the cellar you'll
see like a famous person with their
posse and let go this guy's a funny guy
- there could give a [ __ ] posse
humiliating humiliate cuz then just post
it and you're like thanks yeah then you
then you feel like you should do
something like a little tap dance
respect nothing likes a comedian more
boring than when another comedian says
he's funny to other people because all
you can say is I pre-shock come on man
thanks okay and that's where it dies you
don't sit there and be like you don't
have a just in case somebody says I'm
funny joke in your back pocket no one's
ever been worse and small talk than I am
I'm afraid to approach you sometimes I
feel like you're deep in thought I'm
terrible at it I've always been Michael
laugh at me I'm so bad with your friends
that you know there's nothing to do with
Dave or anybody I've known I'm just bad
at small talk you don't look very
comfortable human being I thought you
were just tired no no no I'm just
fighting my own addictions and then you
know confessions right maybe you should
get on the treadmill one talk around I
have but I went backwards I want to make
it things up whatever the ends it with a
Chevy Chase and I saw a nice old Benny
Hill of the rapist they put together a
therapist for Benny Hill was a funny guy
can I can we go back to guys you would
like to work with sure I would like to
met Benny Hill he has one of the best
lonely deaths I've ever heard of do you
get into this or now I know he died he
was dead for three days no one knew he
was dead and they found him in like his
house he had like five TVs like I guess
he was just watching TV this before that
you know you could read things so they
said it was always really bad at small
talk it's more Lenny that's true just
died doing the hoppers different [ __ ]
on five
he was watching on five TVs and that's
that's how he died well he just died
yeah like this alone watching TV what do
you think of that that's not bad
ways to go you got five TVs I mean
you're probably live channels with all
your Star Wars figure they're
collectible action figures sorry